I'm very pleased to rise today for the third reading of Bill 38
and act respecting child and Family Services,
Indigenous Jurisdiction and other amendments.
This is a historic piece of legislation.
This paves away legislatively in Manitoba for once and for all
decolonizing child welfare
and ensuring that children are in there with their families,
in their communities, in their nations,
being raised by their families,
being raised in their culture and their traditions,
being raised in their language,
being raised on their lands.
I don't know if many people can truly
appreciate how important this legislation is today
when we look at the colonial history of Canada
that has more often than not
been waged on the bodies of children,
of indigenous children, first by way of residential schools,
then by the 60 scoop, and then,
as most would suggest, the continuation in child welfare.
I'm so proud to be a part of a government that is actively pursuing
this path, that's actively pursuing decolonizing child welfare
and reinstating
where the welfare of our children should have always been.
That had always been for thousands of years and many,
many, many generations.
It always rested with our people,
in our territories, in our lands,
with our grandmothers, with our mothers,
with our aunties, with our fathers.
We have always known how to care for our children.
And today writes that wrong
or is at least the beginning steps of writing that wrong.
I want to say a profound Meguitch
to all of the folks that have contributed
to these legislative changes.
Of course, my team in families,
I say it all the time,
I have some of the most extraordinary team members
and I'm so honored to be the minister responsible
to work alongside such a dedicated,
smart and committed individuals
and advancing jurisdiction and decolonizing child welfare.
I want to acknowledge the leadership,
all of our indigenous leadership.
I want to acknowledge and say
Miguel to all of the mothers
and grandmothers
and aunties who have fought to decolonize child welfare.
For as long as I've been doing this work,
not necessarily as the minister of families,
but as an indigenous woman in the community fighting for our rights,
including changes to child welfare,
it has always been LED by women.
It's always been LED by our matriarchs and our grandmothers
and our elders that have sought to decolonize child welfare
and bring our children home where they rightfully belong.
And so today, I say a profound migwhich
to each and every one of those phenomenal women,
including our own special advisor on indigenous women's issues, uh,
Cora Morgan. Cora Morgan was the, uh,
Family Advocate at AMC's, uh,
First Nations Family Advocate Office for seven years.
And her
and her amazing team did phenomenal work at reunifying families
and bringing families together
and also did work, spiritual and cultural work
here on the grounds of the Manitoba Legislative Assembly
back in October of 2020. Uh,
when The former government
sought to legislate the rights of indigenous children away.
They set up camp and for weeks on end had individuals that fasted.
In fact, I was one of the individuals that fasted
alongside one of our colleagues as well.
And they provided that cultural and that spiritual foundation
to be able to do this work in a good way.
And I wanna dedicate Bill 38 to indigenous children.
This legislative framework is in honor of you.
It's in honor of your journey.
It's an honor of everything that you've been through.
But it's also an honor of a path forward.
Our government has a sacred commitment to you
to do all that we can to ensure that these systems aren't needed,
that our families are healthy,
that our families are thriving,
that our families are together,
that our families know and see how beautiful
and strong and loving that they are,
and that the next generation of children,
indigenous children, grow up in our strength.
As indigenous peoples, I always talk about that our people,
our children, our women deserve everything good,
everything good that these lands have to offer everybody else.
Our people deserve nothing but the best.
Our children deserve nothing but the best.
They deserve to be loved and to be safe and to be seen.
And they deserve to be with their families
in their communities and in their nations.
And my solemn commitment and my sacred responsibility is to ensure,
as minister Responsible is to ensure,
but I'm doing everything that I possibly can to ensure that
that is the path forward here for Manitoba.
Make watch.